this morning president Trump is looking
to replace a key member of his
administration and a prominent voice for
the US on the world stage United Nations
ambassador nikki Haley said yesterday
she will resign at the end of the year
the announcement surprised many
administration officials Haley said she
believes in term limits and that it's
time for someone else to do the job
Paula Reid is in Washington with the
latest Paula good morning good morning
ambassador Haley is one of relatively
few high-profile women in the Trump
cabinet and she says she's staying on
through the end of the year to give the
president time to select her replacement
the president said he's thinking of
about five people with some surprising
names making the shortlist on behalf of
the country I want to thank you for
going UN ambassador nikki Haley managed
to make a dignified departure from the
Trump administration she's done a
fantastic job and we've done a fantastic
job together
president Trump said Haley first brought
up resigning six months ago but top
officials were caught off guard by the
announcement including Secretary Pompeo
and national security adviser John
Bolton the United Nations has long been
a hostile place for the State of Israel
Haley is back Trump's hardline stances
on Israel and Iran which often left her
isolated at the UN last month Haley
slammed the anonymous colleague who
wrote a critical op-ed in The New York
Times
Haley said I don't agree with the
President on everything when there is a
disagreement I pick up the phone and
call him or meet with him in person
Thank You mr. prime in her resignation
letter Haley revealed a clue about her
next move writing to the president I
expect you will appreciate my sense that
returning from government to the private
sector is not a step down but a step up
Haley said in her meeting with the
president yesterday she would not run
for office in 2020 recent financial
disclosures reveal Haley is hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt which could
be alleviated by a lucrative private
sector job her office reportedly said
that her dad had no bearing on her
decision to leave president Trump said
he could name Haley's replacement in a
few weeks even suggesting someone very
close to him I think Ivanka would be
incredible but the first daughter
quickly dismissed that suggestion
tweeting that replacement will not be
me the president confirms he is
considering former deputy national
security adviser adviser Deena Powell
she is thought to have a command of the
issues as well as the relationship she
would need in that role we've also
learned that Joe Lieberman the former US
senator and 2000 Al Gore running mate is
also under consideration John all right
Paula thanks